how are you Jeremy I'm rich thanks for
having me I'm now in visiting a social
media coordinator showing our true need
a second a B and a 49ers uniform
explaining that dynamic right has me
laughing you know me Jeremy Fowler
confirms Art Rooney does not have
Instagram on his phone okay that's the
kind of confirm let's put it on the Rich
Eisen show bottom line right there
so how messy is this situation can it
can it at all
even with this Instagram craziness aside
for today be put back into a black and
gold box and run back next year yeah I
do see a small chance to go rich because
already has left the door open a few
times publicly in his recent interviews
that a conversation could go a long way
you know I think it's even some of the
players that I've spoken to they think
it's probably over they say if bran
comes in to show some contrition for
what happened in week 17 that can go a
long way and you know asking around at
the Pro Bowl where I talked to several
Steelers players they all came out full
frontal in support of Brown and for one
of the gathered a lot of the team
leaders have been in contact about this
whole scenario and then basically
decided they're all going to to support
and they're prepared for what happens
either way and they want a more orderly
locker room in 2019 but you know they
it's it's a tough dynamic because he's
very well-liked
despite his issues they love the way
that he works and of course he produces
but they really like the guy and hanging
out with Brown in the piece of locker
room he's just unreliable a lot of spots
well I mean a lot of spots I mean when
the seasons online week week 17 Jeremy
so what did happen week 17 best you can
piece together
well so for a while I was told Brown
actually was in the building on Saturday
at some point but he was not there for
the work session so like a walk through
all that he was not a part of that he
did disappear for most of that and so
everything that I've gathered you know
he felt underappreciated um you know
there was a flare up midweek I don't
think it was as demonstrative as as it
was made out to be after seven players
that I've spoken to who witnessed the
thing you know and Ben and Ben
Roethlisberger and Antonio Brown can't
speak afterwards from what I've gathered
but um it's there are a lot of theories
out there but I still think the
prevailing team is it's a combination of
under appreciation feeling maybe like a
scapegoat you know I know he wasn't
happy with maybe some of the criticisms
from Roethlisberger earlier or after
week 12 in the Denver game about route
running things like that
the emergence of you dismiss Schuester
he likes juju I know they're friends but
in winning the team MVP a lot of players
I've spoken to feel they can't say for
sure but they do feel like that that's a
major factor here on the emergence of
juju and that team MVP that he won and
also you're in your piece intimated
strongly I might add that Browns absence
in week 17 was self-imposed all to point
out how integral he is to shoot juju
Smith Shuster success that he draws
double teams that allows juju Smith
Shuster to have the season than he had
and he was going to show everybody that
without him the offense would struggle
in that regard and sure enough at did
Jeremy
yeah I mean I did this picture team
source that believes that to be the case
but the problem of ground was really
talking to many people that week so a
lot of people are left to theorize on
the situation but you know they knew the
dynamic and and what was happening with
the offense and grounds place in it and
that was certainly a factor well there's
also in this piece to Jeremy Fowler from
ESPN that I want to point out here one
current Steeler that you wrote an
unnamed current Steeler I don't like
seeing a be blamed for all this to me
he's not the problem and then the next
paragraph is the problem according to
player is that the Steelers locker room
issues play out to publicly that's
number seven Jeremy I mean let's not kid
each other here and so how many factions
are there in this locker room right now
well you know I've been in this locker
for about four years now covering the
team and it's really very a normal
locker room for the most guys where guys
just come to work but you have a few all
you know a few players that create a lot
of the headlines and so you know it can
become an issue that way and you know
that that player I spoke to he was a
staunch defender of ground as are many
players and that's sort of the layer to
this discussion that makes it difficult
because on the surface you know Brown
has stepped over the line and they all
know that but it was really just an
accumulation of minor issues over the
years whether you're late to a meeting
or you know you might get a perk or
start treatment that they don't get but
they all saw it as you know for the most
part minor stuff because he works so
hard when he was on the field and on his
own the training and then he produced on
Sundays like that that to them was the
equalizer that's why they don't feel
like he's the problem because he is
you've got a relationship with everybody
in the locker room and he is very
well-liked and so you have you know from
what one player called a love-hate
relationship with with brown and
Roethlisberger I think it's been mostly
love but what we've seen the last two
years and it has played out publicly
there have been some issues and so that
that is a dynamic that it's hard to
ignore but even it's not like
Roethlisberger is demonstrative in the
facility and it's not like he's missing
meetings here you know I mean that's
been the issue with Braun lately he's
not showing up and so it is hard to
blame anybody else in that regard so how
can players how can teammates say yeah
we're cool they'd be if he doesn't show
up at the most important time Jeremy and
that has been confirmed like he did not
he did not show up at the most important
time I mean he needs I've been around
him he's he's infectious you know and I
understand he's dynamite which also
makes it confusing as to why he's filled
he feels unloved when he's absurdly
well-paid and folks like me and you and
everybody else in our business when we
talk about who's the best receiver in
the game he is literally the first if
not second words out of somebody's mouth
so how does this all work I mean how's
it get fixed right well that's that's
where you need some of they're like the
key locker room guys you know the
leaders of veterans to probably come
together and just to say that we give
this is something they can't take
anymore they might need to take out the
pollen or figure something out but
you're right it's a weird dynamic
because you know on one side they
respect them but the patience is
starting to grow thin you know I think
they're supporting them because on some
levels and some of those they have to
because he could very well be back here
they can't work out a trade or he has a
good conversation with ownership and
might on them they work something out
and so you know they certainly want to
be able to work with them but you can
sense the growing frustration there's no
doubt and a lot of the old players or
guys that may be played with Braun
earlier in their career and are now done
and aren't on the team you know that
they think that there's a maybe a
problem where hey the old locker room
wouldn't have tolerated this you know we
had all those you know those defensive
leaders you know Troy Polamalu comes to
mind Joey Porter once upon a time but
those kind of figureheads where you know
grievance is rare and internally and you
try to work it all out and so you know
they point out that maybe this locker
room doesn't have that I think this
locker room would disagree and this is
probably a chance for them to do
something about it but they have
in a lot of cases made apologies for
Brown as well yeah I know I'm Ryan Clark
your colleague at ESPN leaps to mind on
that group as well we had a manual
Sanders on NFL gameday morning where he
thought that that Browns behavior in
week 17 was untenable but he also said
that if Ben Roethlisberger spoke about
him on a radio show in a
passive-aggressive way like he did about
brown and others that he would have a
problem with him and would go up to him
in the locker room and say that so it's
all in I mean it's just everybody's
gonna a little bit of piece of this so
when it all comes down to it does
Antonio Brown have a spot on this roster
week one 2019 season is he is he playing
for the Steelers Jeremy I'm going to say
no right now because you know asking
around the league talking to some folks
you know exact and romanticize they seem
to think he's going to have a small
market but a strong market and then some
team and need to get over the top one
piece away that they'll offer a
first-round ticket some point I probably
enough to do it but you know I mean the
Steelers have to navigate that it's
gonna be about draft capital if they
can't get what they need
but you know I taught the center
marquise bouncy this week he said look
if phone call can just can go a long way
they bit common knows Brown really well
they've been together for a long time he
understands how far Brown is coming his
life and you know Willie rough teenage
years and bouncing around different
schools and so that they have connected
on a human level before if they can
reconnect like that and figure something
out
I don't think it's beyond repair but
it's getting close does I'm gonna keep
going with this with you Jeremy when our
few minutes left Jeremy Fowler does Mike
Talman have a contract extension on the
table week one of the 2019 season I
build on stability I would say so
now they you know I just don't think
they would let it twist in a win
especially when they did win nine games
it was I guess if you're here locally
they would say it's a complete disaster
of a season and considering the talent
that they had it probably is on some
levels but you know you your kicker
flails out lady on Bell top 15 players
Ryan shazier probably top 25 players out
you know he's gone
Antonio parable : for a week there is
there a lot of moving parts I wonder if
the roster was maybe not as talented as
led to believe top to bottom even though
they have some obvious strengths and so
you know I think they still respect the
job that he did but there are some I
mean that the defense needs more of an
identity can't finish games that's a
major issue so that doesn't clean up
next year then it's a different
conversation but I do think every two
years typically in the summer every
other summer day 3 up this contract you
know based on precedent and you know the
stability that comment brings I think
that will get done but there's lots of
shakeout still and then week 1 where is
living on bail do you think you know if
they try to transition tag on or it's
gonna be a big grievance pinnacle PA
you're gonna have all these issues
Belka threatened to sit out again they
can try to do that try to somehow
facilitate a trade but it just seems so
complicated so I still think the
cleanest path for them let him go to
free-agency
get your comp pick third-round pick
whatever it's gonna be and I'm gonna say
the Jets a lot of people say the Colts
from what I've gathered I do not think
the Colts will get living on bail I
think it just going to be a team of the
ton of money that that you know needs a
playmaker so I could see bucks I could
see Jets so their cue to come to my last
one for you week one of the 2019 season
this Ben Roethlisberger have a local
radio show that's up on the air will he
will he have a radio show or will the
Steelers say that's over and whatever
you're making off of it or getting for
your charity from it we will cut you a
check will they do that I doubt it I
mean just give the president of Court of
I strongly having it if they did that
then that would create a whole nother
power struggle that they could come up
with Jeremy they could come up with
however you want to call it that he's
spending time with his family he's just
gonna tap out he's focusing more on
football there's so many ways to handle
it but there's
question you know and obviously that
microphones will be put in front of him
on Wednesdays just as he is all the time
but there's no reason why there should
be some sort of 20-minute forum in which
something always gathers a more bizarre
news cycle or more steam because of what
he's saying in these right got a session
oh and pom pom of the building like
years ago and there's a quarter out
there saying I'm not gonna sit up here
every week and address what Ben says on
his radio show I just don't see the
Steelers checking them on that I think
they see that as even though it can be a
distraction they see that as not though
it's not winning I really think common
doesn't worry a lot about that stuff I
really don't Jeremy so he can say it
yeah you know but I don't think they're
gonna do anything about it
Jeremy thanks for the call appreciate it
anytime you bet thanks again for up for
the piece and for the phone call it's
probably over how it's gone wrong with
Antonio Brown and the Steelers and then
there's so many other Nuggets in here
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience